Hello, and welcome to the Epic Games training for Unreal Engine Tools, Source Control, and
Collaboration.
My name is Kevin Miller, and I'm an instructor for Epic Games.
In this course, we'll start out by helping you with understanding Source Control's core
concepts and basic workflows.
Then we'll look at server and client setup as we explore where to go and install Perforce.
Then how to get your project into Perforce.
After that, we will briefly compare ShotGrid and Perforce as version control options
before taking a look at how Epic Games utilizes ShotGrid in our production pipeline.
Next, we'll look at version control inside Unreal Engine, and then explore Unreal Game
Sync as an alternative to using the Perforce interface for project synchronization.
We will also look at existing collaboration tools and see how it all comes together in
your production pipeline.
Finally, we will wrap up the course with a few final recommendations that cover organization,
tips, and resources.
Additionally, as you work through this course material, we will be providing a project file
that you can upload to your own version control solution.
The project file is the UET 216-06 demo, and it makes use of the Downtown West modular
pack by Pure Polygons that can be found in the Epic Games Marketplace permanently
free collection.
Be sure to download that and add it to your library.
Now, let's move on to our next section to help you understand Source Control.